efectivamente muy importante alan
recordemos que estuvo en el origen del
consejo europeo de la unión monetaria
como la conocemos hoy fue uno de los
propulsores del voto universal en el
parlamento europeo y una vez que salió
de la presidencia y pasó al parlamento
europeo él fue uno de los constructores
de la unión política que nunca
finalmente fue realizada el unión
europea- angela merkel dice alemania ha
perdido a un amigo recordemos que fue
giscard está en quien puso a la pareja
franco-alemana en el centro de la
construcción europea la presidenta de la
comisión europea ursula von der leyen le
dice en el corazón de giscard están los
destinos de francia y de europa estaban
unidos y obviamente desde el presidente
del consejo europeo también viene un
recuerdo para giscard d'estaing dijo él
creó el consejo europeo que sentó las
bases de la unión monetaria europea como
la conocemos hoy en día
alan tras la muerte del ex presidente de
francés los homenajes se siguen
multiplicando erika además del minuto de
silencio en el parlamento que actos se
esperan
el más importante a la nueva ya las ocho
de la noche el presidente emmanuel
macrón va a hablar en cadena nacional
para recordar a valéry giscard d'estaing
como ya lo hizo cuando falleció jacques
chirac
recordemos que debido a este discurso ha
tenido que suspender una entrevista que
iba a dar al medio de internet brutten
que iba a hablar sobre la situación de
la juventud en la pandemia y sobre las
polémicas y violencias policiales que
han despertado la ira de los ciudadanos
franceses y no císcar de estaña había
pedido a su familia un funeral discreto
en el círculo privado solamente en
familia y es lo que ha dicho su familia
que va a respetar esa última voluntad
también pidió ser enterrado en el jardín
de su casa cerca de tur su casa de campo
pero eso todavía no se sabe si va a
ocurrir pues se necesita una
autorización la familia quería construir
una capilla funeraria dentro de la
propiedad